after seemingly endless bad news about
covert there could finally be some green
shoots
of optimism appearing the number of new
covered 19 infections is falling and a
vaccine could start to be rolled out
before the end of the year
so when could life start to return to
something
like normality or joining us from
liverpool is professor kellem semple who
sits on the government scientific
advisory group
sage thank you very much for being with
us um the prime minister
set to announce tomorrow that people
will be able to meet their loved ones
over the christmas period
is allowing household mixing at
christmas a good idea
well in reality we cannot ban christmas
and to do so would just lead to breaches
and what are you're going to do about
that so so instead what we're what we're
looking at
is getting r if you like down but also
getting the absolute numbers of cases
down
and there's real there's real good news
here nationally we're seeing cases in
the community fall
and in those areas that went into tier
three before lockdown
we're already seeing the tide turning
with the number of hospital admissions
and we'll shortly see the death
deaths reduce as well so there's every
reason to believe
that when lockdown is lifted many areas
will be able to go into lower tiers but
some areas
will remain in higher tiers
then you've got this period in the
run-up to christmas and hopefully
if if this system works we'll be able to
relax some regulations for a few days
but there will be a price for that you
say there'll be a price for it and
public health england said
that every day that restrictions are
relaxed we could see five days of
tighter restrictions as a result is that
assessment broadly right
do you think yeah i think i think in the
round
it's right but it shouldn't be seen that
it's going to be draconian restrictions
it's just going to prolong
restrictions and a higher level of
restriction
for some for some areas and perhaps all
areas as a whole
it's very hard to know because we're
talking about human behavior here
we know that restrictions work we also
know that we need to open up the economy
so there's a very difficult balancing
act here
and the vaccine won't come soon enough
for the general population
and it's within the general population
that most most household contacts take
place most
personal care contacts take place and
it's these
um intimate interactions prolonged
personal interactions that drive
our back up again interesting that
you're saying that you know the vaccine
rollout won't happen in the math
population for some time yet
when do you think we could start to see
the return to normality that people are
hoping for
the vaccine priorities will inevitably
be the the most vulnerable and the front
front line healthcare workers it won't
be academics like me
and i think we'll be seeing that phased
out in in
around christmas and new year because we
the vaccines already
already ordered and we've got excellent
results
for the rest of the population i think
we'll be looking towards the summer
before there's
mass vaccination of the rest of the
population and and
that's what will give us the immunity
the broad immunity
that allows us to return to normal but
having said that there's still going to
be vulnerable people where
we will need to take care and in general
this has taught us
about the importance of hand washing and
good ppe
that we need in our care homes and our
hospitals
we've had we've had rotavirus norovirus
mrsa there's lots of other things out
there
so we do need to learn from this and
improve our general infection prevention
control measures
so if um you say that you know the most
majority of the population might not be
vaccinated until the summer do you think
we will
we're facing social distancing until
next summer realistically
i i i doubt that because
if we can vaccinate the frail and the
elderly
then that will take the pressure off the
groups that will be coming into hospital
with severe disease
we do still have a core of particularly
women aged between 20 and 50
20 and 40 particularly where we're
seeing three or four times more
admissions of these women
than men that's really not been well
explained but it does seem to match
their roles
in hospitality health care entertainment
injuries
in industry and many of them are going
on to have
long covert so there will be a strong
push
to get the vaccination throughout the
community and not
just focus on the elderly but they've
the elderly than the frail people and
those medical conditions will come first
but i do think we will be seeing um a
restriction of the
restrict lifting of the restrictions in
the spring and i i think there's a lot
to be optimistic about here
we've also got a really good really good
ways of looking after people now so
death rates
in hospital fallen from one and three to
one in six so there's lots to be
optimistic about here
lovely to get bit of optimistic news in
these interviews normally it's just been
kind of doom and gloom so it's nice to
have
a sliver of hope as well and i was quite
struck by what you were saying about
um younger women or women between 20 and
40
and catching covid perhaps because of
their role in hospitality and
industry and i just wonder what that
means for the general restrictions that
we're likely to
enter into from the second of december
because we've been told that there'll be
a strengthened
tier system for england perhaps an
acknowledgement that the one before
wasn't quite tight enough
what do you think that strength and tier
system needs to look like
do pubs and restaurants for example need
to close do we need to be much more
tighter on household mixing i'm going to
be really difficult here
what we as advisors do is provide best
evidence and there's some really good
evidence here about exactly which
sectors are
responsible if you like for transmission
we know a lot more about the roles of
cinemas hospitality food production
warehouses
health and social care and in fact right
down to the levels of nail salons beauty
beauty parlors barbers ladies
hairdressers into two parlors
so all that information is now in the
mix and we know we can tell that with
really good accuracy that information
gets passed to ministers and they
will decide and you won't be surprised
that i'm not going to prejudice
the uh or or be seen to be lobbying one
way or the other or
contradicting what's what difficult
decisions are going to be made today
um yeah i absolutely understand and the
the difficulties shall we say in being a
sage advisor and making sure you don't
want to break any confidences
or also talk about decisions that are
ultimately political
could you give us a bit of a steer on
what the data does show about where the
higher risk areas of transmission are
yeah there's some real surprises in here
construction industry
you'd have thought working outside
wouldn't be a risk but many people in
construction are actually working inside
inside before buildings are made
essentially covered safe
so construction industry has turned out
to be a risk that
i was surprised to see but other other
areas are exactly as you predict
high risk around food production whereas
it was indoors poorly ventilated kept
quite cold
so you don't have high air flows and
workers working very closely together
the other ones are quite obvious but you
can't do much about them
health and social care is such a key
part of society you can't
we know that it's associated with
exposure and risk but we can't shut that
down it's not going to be we're not
going to close health and social care
down
uh when we come out of shut down so so
that's why it's such a difficult
uh a difficult decision to make we
essentially
have so much more information now and we
can target exactly what areas are
responsible
we do know that pubs clubs social clubs
cinemas are associated with transmission
and and
there's no easy way out of saying that
they are
problem areas and whereas in the summer
we could use the beer gardens
and drink outside we don't have that
liberty now
yeah a bit chilly uh to do that now uh
certainly and
some of the industries that you
mentioned hairdressers for example
pubs have taken quite a lot of covered
precautions with the use of face masks
or
trying to socially distance where
possible has that made any difference
according to the data
i think according to the data uh we can
still identify these as very high risk
activities
on an individual basis there will be
people that have
adhered strongly to using these
mechanisms of protection and that will
have protected them
but as in all things the underlying
activity is risky
and it doesn't take much you just touch
your mask when you shouldn't have then
you pick up the scissors and you adjust
the fair hair you wipe something out of
somebody's eye
and all of a sudden you you've broken
the barriers so it's not just a case of
oh just bang on some
bang on a mask and advisor it's about
not touching the face mask it's about
washing your hands
and it's difficult it takes nurses and
doctors years to learn how to do this
properly
and it's very very difficult if you
remember the public to
to get into the swing of using ppe
effectively
and there's a lot of um speculation that
the 10 pm
curfew could be scrapped or at least
adapted so that you know you
order last orders or at 10pm but you've
got an hour to finish drinking up and do
you think that would make any difference
to transmission
okay so one of the one of the one of the
features here is that history has got a
lot to teach us
and in the years of prohibition they uh
tried to change the drinking hours they
tried to say you could only drink
if you had a meal and everyone's very
inventive
and finds ways around it so i think
making fiddling at the edges of
something like
drinking up times and pubs closing times
is simply
not not an effective mechanism i think
with with pubs and clubs
you have to look at the whole human
behavior and take human behavior into
account
and i think that's what was missing when
the when when this
first came in i think whatever iteration
you see next will be better informed
by understanding human behavior and not
driving
as into an unintended consequence that
can increase
transmission such as closing the pubs
early and everyone
turfing out onto the streets at once i
think i think that's
that's one of the lessons we've learned
and and history has got lots to teach us
here
yeah we all remember those pictures so
everyone piling out onto the street
after closing time and thank you so much
for coming on the program it's been
really fascinating to
talk through some of that data with you
thank you